they said well can you tell us a little
bit more
and the next day i had the role leading
in powerful wow globally throughout the
world
[Music]
cheryl thank you so much for being on 20
minute leaders it's so great to have you
here
oh wonderful to join you michael where
are you coming from
ah i am i'm sheltering in place in palo
alto
okay i live in new york city but i
figured i'd get a little bit more
freedom here
since i have a puppy definitely how old
is the puppy how old is gabby
uh gabby which is short for gabriel
god's bravest woman uh is two and a half
years old
and my best friend so she's not a puppy
anymore
i would call her a puppy i call all dogs
puppy
okay wonderful no because i have a
three-month-old puppy and i'm waiting
for him to get out of the puppy phase
so that i can stop calling him a puppy
yeah it's about another year
that's longer than most people told me
so i'm not going to take that answer but
but we'll just move on okay
so cheryl is such an impressive
background a global executive on all
fronts
uh so many different enterprises you're
involved with the whole with the whole
prize which i'd love to talk more about
you're very involved with women and
leadership and and and
broadcasting a positive message around
that can you please give me
is it sort of a really short intro about
where you came from
and and what are the things that are
that are most exciting to you right now
oh where we come from i think i come
from a place and sorry i'm moving around
because i want to make perfect
but i think we all come from a place in
our lives where our family has helped us
understand a little bit more about who
we are and what we can be
and for me my father was that person
that said you can be anybody you want to
be and you don't need anybody else to
help you get there
so as a person in life i've always
looked at
who i am as what's possible as opposed
to what's not possible
and growing up in a city like new york
city and having the freedom to go
anywhere and do
anything no matter how old you are and
still survive
really teaches you that sense that hey
i'm me and i have confidence and through
that confidence
i can take on anything so women's
leadership
and leadership overall not just women
women and men to be honest with you
because we do this together
is about teaching people to be confident
and not see themselves at
the face that they see in the mirror but
see themselves as the heart
and soul and driven human being that
they want to be in this world
that's who i am what is so so what is
that give me a little bit more
background about this specific notion
of helping people transition from just
seeing them their faces in the mirror to
seeing a
more confident being what does that
entail and how do you even go about
trying to help that transformation i
think it starts in a very simple way
i mean often times we go up to little
girls and we say you're cute you're so
pretty
but we go up to little boys and we say
you're strong you're capable
go get it and so that very fundamental
starting point needs to change we need
to pivot it
so if girls see themselves as strong
capable then from that place they won't
see themselves in the mirror and that's
the role
that my father played in my life saying
you're interesting
people never said i was cute or pretty
until i was over 25.
so you think that it's literally about
having the adjectives being one is more
characteristic of our appearance and one
is more characteristic of our soul
that makes a pretty significant
difference already in these
younger ages i think younger ages and
throughout your life
so i think this notion of people seeing
themselves
as people and responding to them in that
way
teaches them who they are i often see on
facebook
a woman posts a new photo hey i got a
new haircut look at me
and i say you look strong you look
capable
and and i like your haircut you're
gorgeous so i
start with i change i love it yes and
that's how i build the relationship with
that woman
as opposed to just commenting as
others do and once you build that level
of relationship because that's what they
want to hear like who
am i then they're opening the door to
say well how can you help me get to be
the person i want to be
totally okay so and and do you do that
work
is is that just independently is that is
that through a
a more through an organization or or
some other
structured area how does that actually
take place yeah i think if you're really
going to make
impact you have to work through an
organization because it gives you that
lift
it brings you up and it gives you power
and a position
to work from so wherever i have worked
i've found a way into their women's
organizations
um the current one that i'm involved in
is at the company i work for koopa
which is for business spend management
what salesforce is for customer
relationship management so
amazing company whose culture is
interesting because it's
upside down management so what does that
mean
yeah the ceo set it up that he's on the
bottom
instead of the top and then his leaders
report to him
and then when you finally get to
somebody like me you know
i'm now towards the top so that
upside down management allows you to
bring new ideas forward more quickly
and you have the sense that you're
empowered so
give me a slightest example so i i get
the idea of an upside up pyramid but i
don't understand what does that mean
that his leaders are reporting to him
even though he's somewhat beneath them
how does that actually yeah
it means that um anytime we roll out
something new to the market and
one example is what i'm running now
which is called empower that's their
diversity women's organization
okay i didn't interview for it
i just said hey i know you hired me for
alliances i'm good at
alliances building relationships that
yeah these drive
outcomes and results financial business
results
i said but i also know a lot about
diversity inclusion and i've been doing
this
for 15 years they said well can you
tell us a little bit more and the next
day i had the
role leading in power forward wow
globally throughout the world
and now i'm building the board and
setting the agenda defining the pillars
and that happened within days and now
it's a couple of weeks
so you don't normally see that in
companies you see physical
jockeying like who are you you just got
here
and here it's like oh that's you yay we
love
it and another example and i have to be
like
pretty excited about it to share this
but um
every time someone is promoted has a
baby
or sells something they send a note to
all of us
so that everybody can congratulate them
two thousand people in the comments
that's great
so so that says a little bit more about
how the
people are as important as the outcomes
that you deliver
of course of course no i mean especially
i mean today in 2020
culture is so apparent and such a such a
centerpiece of every company maybe i
don't think it was like that 10 15 years
ago right correct me if i'm wrong
this focus and this challenge uh it's
pretty pretty insane tell me a little
bit about this holds price that you're
very involved with ah
so that's my other favorite story so a
whole prize
which is now in its 10th year is the
world's
largest social impact organization what
it is
it's a challenge that's put out to every
student at every university around the
world
to solve a social problem that impacts
10 million people in five years
so so you solve it within five years but
it impacts 10 million people right in
five years that's kind of the overall
president clinton puts out the challenge
to the students at these universities
they compete on campus to be the campus
winner
to go further along the challenge
and ultimately the winning team gets a
million dollars in seed money
to take their idea forward and to start
wow for
profit for good business so the notion
is
for profit is very for profit for profit
for good
for profit for good a million dollar
seed yeah
grant no strings attached just you know
milestone okay well of course you you
want to help them as they're moving
along the way
no of course but but there's no equity
there's no
equity driven wow and so what's your
role over there
so i came in to lead the
all the mentors that have been involved
over the years
for these young students to take a
nascent idea
and build it into something that can
become a business
you need people that understand
alliances business
business models presenting marketing
everything that's needed
so i i bring my friends in who are now
the mentors
including the ceo of microsoft in sweden
a friend of mine that worked in shark
tank so he ran ran all that
so i just kind of picked and she chose
so cool
it's really cool and they all go oh
cheryl can i do it again this year like
yeah sure but i got a lot of other
people that are interested
wow so so give me some examples of these
these projects just so that i can wrap
my
mind around what what constitutes a halt
winner project yes so one of them
and i'm an advisor to it is um the
challenge that years was
early childhood education ages zero to
six
so that's a very hard challenge because
zero to six
you have different educational needs
that are there um
but the the idea that one that year was
the notion of creating
and you're yeah of creating a school and
using that school to help train these
are essentially educate children but the
school is very special
in that the school is in the growing
communities for coffee
so think about all the coffee growers
and
their communities that they're growing
coffee how did the children get educated
in a more strategic way instead of
one-on-one
parents children so they created schools
and so they trained the mothers how to
be educators
and they bring that education into the
community and
a percentage of all the coffee that is
sold
is used to go back into those
communities to build these schools
so it's a very cool idea it's called
impact
impact coffee so we have to get you some
i'll order
it's done definitely oh my god wait so
and
how so how long have you been involved
with this how many projects have you
really seen go through
um i've been involved for over seven
years
and i've seen some really amazing
projects go through but it's not about
the projects
it's about lighting up people at
university
to know that in addition to what they
want to be
they want to make the world a better
place i love it okay
we instill that in every person and
you know the mentors the advisors the of
course
then we start to build a world that is
like koopa a village
that there's much more to life than just
making money
i love it i love it okay cheryl talk to
me a little bit about alliances what
does that even mean
building alliances building
relationships uh
you're you're kind of an expert in that
but i have no idea what that is
i'm still a little kid yeah i simplified
it's how you bring
people together from different points of
view and different backgrounds
to come together to create a for a
common purpose
to deliver more outcomes so now you're
going to say be specific
um so when i manage the alliance between
emc
or dell dell emc and vmware so dell
is a hardware company vmware is a
virtualization company
they didn't really understand like why
do i need hardware to be virtualized
so through alliances you built
relationships with company like
other companies like ibm or hp or netapp
to integrate virtual capability into
their technology
so that when they sell it to their
clients they have better value but
vmware's selling this offer
so alliances is really honestly it's
about taking different
parts different backgrounds or different
capabilities
putting them together and delivering a
better value
proposition to the market yeah i mean so
you're kind of an integrator where you
know
the overall challenges or or of both
organizations and you're trying to play
matchmaker
like cupid and saying yeah i think we
can they can help you with this and you
can help them with that
let's we can form some some lines that
wouldn't have come up otherwise right
is that a fair way to put it yeah but
what i also do is i get engineers from
different organizations to say hey i
want to work with you
what you have is good and then i
marketing oh i want to market with you
sales i want to sell with you so it's
about looking
at the whole life cycle that sits inside
of an organization
and aligning all across all of those
different avenues and when you do that
that's how you really bring value and
deliver an outcome
that's successful on both sides sure
another example i worked at metadata
which is a life sciences platform
which was so cool i mean imagine today
working
in that arena what they did is they help
bring drugs to market more quickly by
building a platform that life sciences
companies can
do to ensure that as they're going
through all of the medical
tests that need to happen to bring a
drug to market which think about that
today how important that is
so you need a system integrator or an
alliance company
to help manage the services around that
so that when it's delivered you have the
technology services and the customer
all working together that's another
example of an alliance
very cool and and so how much of that
does require technological background
versus more people skills relationships
really understanding and how to read
strategically yeah you really have to
understand people to do this
yeah fundamental but you have to be
savvy enough
about technology so you don't show up in
the room as just a people person because
they don't listen to you
yep but if you if you bring really smart
technologists in that room the
technologists
love the people side and so they give
you all the
the technical capability but i
understand technology i'm just not
i'm not a real geek but my family thinks
i'm a geek
i love it i love it i love it okay sure
and and so what actually excites you
know
in the day to day i love asking that
because you know so many people are
have such fascinating positions some of
them are passionate about them some of
them are passionate about other things
is this what you're really passionate on
the core of alliances
or is that or or are there bits and
pieces also that are missing from there
i'm passionate about people i mean i
really want
to create a world where we're all
connected and
understand as my friend carrie anderson
always says we are better together
and we have a lot of unintended allies
that we need to understand so
as we do for others we create this
new world that takes us forward together
so i mean that's really what i care
about and i
mostly care about connecting
multi-generational people
understand that we're all dealing with
things and we can learn yeah
i learn from you you learn from me
one way and i think that's what i'm
passionate about the other thing is
i love dogs so i'm i'm sheltering a
place here in stamford
you're wearing a shirt but hello alto
because
i can go out here and run around and go
for a
five mile hike or run bring my pup
she meets another dog and then you know
we all hang out together so
that's the other side of me i love it i
love it
okay and i'd love to also get to know a
little bit about
uh your ears your earned secrets
i would say about alliance's overall
over these years and
i'm i'm gonna use alliances as sort of a
metaphor for
peop for relationship building which is
such a fundamental aspect of today's
businesses and i'm looking at myself
you know as a future ceo and looking for
these alliances and looking for
partnerships what what should i be
looking for or strive to
to look for as i'm preparing for these
relationships
building a world where what you say
and what you do is so honest and true
that people around you want to be with
you and
be involved um that's number one i mean
that essence of sounds like leadership
right it is leadership
but i mean wherever you are you you need
to be a leader but that fundamental
respect of other people
is is critical and important and then
also
just taking a moment to always say to
somebody thank you i like what you do i
recognize it and
never take the position that you've done
it it's you it's us it's hard
it's hard sometimes to step back and
give it and take a few minutes to
acknowledge
especially you know today as everything
is moving so quickly
and it's sometimes hard to just step
back and say wait wait let's take a
moment to acknowledge
what we just did here yeah but if you
don't
then what are you going to get it's
those small moments that make the big
moments
huge i mean i posted something yesterday
incorrectly and
somebody i worked for sent me a note uh
oh
um i don't think you meant to do this
but it's a you can fix it if you want to
but uh oh i just want you to know
don't worry about it so what a nice way
to say
hey you made a mistake you know you may
want to fix it for you but i don't care
about it for me
those soft ways of helping someone else
look better
helps build relationships between people
yeah i definitely know
and you know one of the really
interesting things that i've been
observing since i came to palo alto over
about a year ago is also the way in
which you help people correct and how
direct you can be versus non-direct
obviously the israeli culture is very
different from american culture and
there's a lot of adaptations
uh a lot of adaptations to do this it's
definitely been fascinating for me
cheryl before we end i i have to put you
on the spot once
and i'd love to know three words that
you would best describe yourself as or
one of your colleagues would describe
you as or your puppy would describe you
as
oh no i don't have those three words
passionate authentic and driven
do you have those three words that was
easy
yeah i would add people at the end
because i am very playful
i love it i think i think that i think
those are really what you need to
to be to have strong alliances and
strong relationships and
it sounds like what you're doing both of
the halt prize is incredible and the
with the diversification and women and
leadership and men in leadership it's
it's fantastic and i love your take on
on alliances building and
relationships and i'm definitely taking
a lot of these things to myself
also as a as a future entrepreneur and
it says cheryl thank you very much for
your time
stay safe and stay healthy very good you
too bye-bye
[Music]
you